hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast accelerating immuno
oncology research with the pan-cancer IO
360 gene expression panel advanced data
analysis service and the signature
development presented by dr. sara warren
director of advanced applications immune
oncology at nano string and dr. Patrick
Stannah her at principal bio
statistician at nano string I'm Susie
Valdes of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by nano string nano
stream technologies is a provider of
life science tools for translational
research and molecular diagnostics the
company's molecular barcoding technology
enables a wide variety of basic research
translational medicine and in vitro
diagnostic applications before we begin
I want to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on that green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type those questions into the box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge that
window just click on that screen icon
located on the lower right if you have
any trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation click on the support button
at the top right of the presentation
window or use that Q&A button and let us
know you're having a problem good news
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me now
in welcoming our presenters dr. sarah
warren and dr. patrick Danaher i will
now turn the presentation over to our
speakers welcome to both of you
thank you Susie and thank you for the
very nice introduction my name is sarah
warren i am the director of advanced
applications at nano string and i'm
going to spend a few minutes today to
talk with you about
one of our newest products which is the
pan-cancer IO 360 gene expression panel
and as part of this talk I'm going to
explain to you about some of the
wonderful features that we've built into
the panel and how we think that it can
accelerate research in the IO community
and then I'm going to pass the
presentation over to my colleague dr.
Danaher who's going to then go on to
explain and introduce you to some of the
advanced data analysis services that we
are building in parallel to support this
new expression panel so thanks you know
with that I'm going to advance the
slides to talk with you a bit about the
state of immuno on ecology today so
since you've joined us on the for this
presentation I assume that you are
familiar with immuno on ecology as a
research field and as a as a field with
many clinical applications and I'm sure
you are familiar as well with the cancer
immunity cycle which were showing up on
this first slide and so this is the
concept that is there's a hypothesis to
explain how tumors in the immune system
interact to shape the balance between
tumor host permissiveness and tumor host
responds to the cancer which shapes
whether the immune system becomes
activated to recognize and eliminate the
cancer or whether the tumor is allowed
to persist so as you can see there's
many potential sites of intervention
within this tumor immunity cycle and
many new therapies are being developed
which which may have the potential to
disrupt the cancer immunity cycle and to
initiate immune responses that lead to
ultimate clearance and protection
against the tumor so at nano string it
is our goal to build research tools
which can seek to leverage the power of
gene expression profiling to understand
how the balance between the tumor and
the immune system is existing with any
given patient and then how potential
therapies may be altering that balance
to to shape
clinical outcomes and and by using
multiplex to gene expression profiling
we believe we can create a complete
holistic picture of what's happening for
within any given patient so there's a
lot of research that has been ongoing
into cancer immunotherapy at the moment
these this slide is highlighting just a
few of the major publications that have
come out just in the past year which
really seek to provide different
frameworks for understanding again how
tumor and alanine systems are
interacting and nano string leverages
publications and latest research such as
these along with our own internal
research to build gene expression panels
that are going to be highly informative
and highly useful for all of our users
and really our ultimate goal here is to
not just to provide static gene
expression profiles but we really want
to be part of the solution for providing
better a better therapies to patients in
need and we really want to be part of
the community which is helping to
generate more effective immuno oncology
drugs and then to understand how those
drugs can be most effectively deployed
into the right patient populations and
alone or in combination with other
therapies to provide the greatest
likelihood of clinical benefit and
ultimately what we'd want to do is help
direct the right therapies to the right
to the right patients and we believe we
can do that using the gene expression
profiles and the assays that we are
developing here at Nana's ring so I want
to start off by telling you about one of
these assays which is called our tumor
inflammation signature so this is a
signature that we have been developing
with our partners at Merck it is based
upon gene expression profiling of
pretreatment tumor biopsies and Merck
began this project with the goal of
developing a predictive signature to
identify patients who were likely to
respond to the pd-1 therapy parallelism
app so Merck was a longtime ministering
customer they were using custom gene
code sets to generate signatures
and prototype gene expression
classifications from their patients that
they had acquired through clinical
trials and we're seeking to understand
what gene expression patterns look like
when they court when the patient's were
experiencing benefit from Humble ism app
so they were working on their own but
then they reached out to nana stream to
leverage our expertise in Diagnostics to
really develop a an analytical clinical
assays that could be used across a
variety of tumor settings to identify
those patients who were most likely to
respond to Pemberley the map so this
slide is just showing you a bit of what
the of what the clinical development of
the tumor inflammation signature looked
like Merck initially began by looking at
a a cohort of patients from one of their
melanoma trials where they did a
discovery cohort with a very small
number of patients and then validated a
preliminary signature and what you can
see is that in patients that had a a
positive clinical response September
ilysm AB there was an elevated signature
here that was observed versus those
patients that did not experience
clinical benefit Merck then went on to
to refine this signature further by
looking at other tumor types and in both
the head and that cancer in the gastric
cancer they again saw that the signature
could be predictive of patients with
good clinical response and they refined
the signature they refined the algorithm
that supported the signature to continue
to develop something that would be even
more predictive and at that point we
formed we joined with them and nano
string came on and worked to do a series
of training exercises to develop an
assay that would become the final locked
down clinical test which would be taken
to the FDA in order to be a companion
diagnostic for Pember lism app and
really to seek to characterize the
immune biology that was most reflective
of responses to member lizmac so that
work was summarized in this paper that
came out over the summer in Journal of
Clinical Investigation
it was led by our colleagues at marks
it describes very briefly the clinical
development which I told you about just
a minute ago and then goes into much
more detail about how this signature
performs in a variety of clinical
settings I would encourage you to look
up this paper and you know you know read
it and understand it and you know reach
out to us please if you have any
questions about how this signature could
be applied to your work let me tell you
a little bit more about the biology of
the tumor inflammation signature it's an
18 gene signature which is measuring the
presence of a peripherally suppressed
adaptive immune response within the
tumor and that's a lot of words so let
me explain in more detail what that
means the signature itself is a way of
determining whether tumors have an
inflamed phenotype so whether they're
immune hot or immune cold it's doing
this by analyzing four different areas
of biology and you can see those listed
on the right side of the slide so we're
really asking four key questions first
our antigen presenting cells present
within the tumor and if yes also our RT
and NK cells are effector cells present
here in the tumor and then if both those
cells are present we're also looking
then for evidence that the T cells and
the NK cells have become activated by
looking for genes associated with
interferon biology and finally at the
same time we're measuring for genes
which are indicative of t-cell
exhaustion and this is identifies genes
is identifying a patient population that
may be likely to respond to PT one
checkpoint blockade the tumor
inflammation signature is measuring the
immune genes so it's not measuring tumor
intrinsic gene expression patterns and
as such it makes it a pan-cancer tumor
signature which means that the same test
can be applied across many different
indications and in work that we are
doing and work that is ongoing at merck
Weir the tumor inflammation signature is
being investigated in comparison to
other biomarkers which are already in
the clinic or in clinical development
right now and we've seen very good
responses with comparing the TI F to PDL
1 immunohistochemistry as well as
mutational load profile
so I want to give you I want to start
off by showing you just one example of
how the tumor inflammation signature can
be used to identify patients who may be
good candidates for PT one checkpoint
blockade this is a figure from the Eyres
paper where we're looking across many
different tumor types to understand how
clinical response is and in this case
it's progression free survival
correlates with the tumor inflammation
signature so the tumor inflammation
signature score is listed across the
x-axis here in this paper it was called
the gene expression profile or GE P and
progression-free survival is indicated
on the y-axis and what you can see is
that we've color-coded this the
patient's here based upon their clinical
response those patients that had very
good clinical response based on on
radiographic signals are indicated in
red squares those patients that have
intermediate responses are are in blue
triangles and those patients with poor
clinical outcomes are indicated in black
circles and you can see that the data
really segregate out into three
different three different areas on this
graph those patients in the upper
right-hand quadrant are the patients who
had a very high t is score and also
experienced very prolonged clinical
response after receiving member
Elizabeth mono therapy so this is
telling us that these are the patients
for whom member lizmac was the right
drug in this setting in contrast those
patients that are on the left side of
the graph for those patients who had a
very low TI f score and who also didn't
benefit when they received PEM bro so
these are the patients who had a lack of
an immune response already in their
tumor so treating them with PD one
checkpoint blockade was not enough to to
overcome that immune suppression these
patients may need a different course of
therapy to help them activate immune
responses and recruit immune cells to
the tumor and we believe that by looking
at the gene expression profiles of these
particular patients we may be able to
understand where that particular immune
defect is occurring finally the
patient's on the lower right side of the
graph for those patients that had a high
tumor inflammation signature but
did not experience clinical benefit from
PD one checkpoint blockade and so these
are the patients who may have more than
one mechanism of immune evasion present
and active within their tumors and they
may be good candidates for a combination
immunotherapy approach which can
overcome these multiple different
blockades at the same point and again we
believe that by looking at the gene
expression profiles we can understand
how you know how these are these four
patients should be directed towards
appropriate therapies I mentioned before
that the tumor inflammation signature
was a pan tumor assay but I wanted to
provide some data to support that that a
certain so this is looking at the tumor
inflammation signature from eleven
different tumor types and each tumor
type is indicated across the top of this
graph by a different color and you can
see that we've organized these samples
from the T is low to the T is highest
scores going left to right here and and
there is not an intrinsic clustering of
the different tumor types to one region
of T is score versus the other so this
is telling us that again as we believed
by looking at the biology the tumor
inflammation signature is really
measuring the fundamental immune
response within the tumor rather than
gene expression coming from the tumor
cells themselves and finally I mentioned
as well that we are comparing the tumor
inflammation signature to other
potential biomarkers so I um you know
one of the reasons that we really
believe in the power of the T is is that
it's using the gene expression profiling
to directly interrogate the immune
biology within the tumor we have
preliminary evidence that shows that
this test may have better predictive
power than PDL one immunohistochemistry
and we are currently developing this now
as a clinical trials asset which may be
deployed into registration 'el trials so
this has been developed very rigorously
under GOP conditions for use in
investigational research settings and
finally since its
stephane and in a string platform this
is a decentralized model so these this
asset can be run wherever there is an
encounter instrument installed an in
place in contrast to the tumor
information signature other biomarkers
which are currently in development for
use as predictors for immunotherapy I
have some significant problems with
their with them as asses so the one that
is approved as a diagnostic right now is
the PDL one immunohistochemistry asset
this is a single biomarker analyte it's
an analyte biomarker which is just
measuring the presence and localization
of the PDL one protein within a tumor
biopsy and the PDL one protein is known
to be very diversity regulated with
regards to spacial profiling it is
regulated temporally it is very a very
dispersed um in terms of the
distribution that you see when you look
at patient samples and consequently the
PDL one assay is it has very low
predictive power in terms of identifying
patients that will respond to checkpoint
blockade in addition to variations
intrinsic to the biology PDL one
expression since this is an immunity
immunohistochemistry assay it's relying
upon at the end of the day a subjective
interpretation of that test to
appropriately assign the patients to a
given score and then potentially a given
their therapeutic course of treatment
the other asset which is in clinical
development now is to measure a variety
of s is to measure tumor mutational
burden and this is an intriguing
hypothesis for developing new biomarkers
unfortunately the tumor mutation burden
is sort of intrinsically limited because
it's a again a single measurement of one
facet of tumor biology so it's really
looking for the presence of potential
neo antigens within a tumor
other than looking at the downstream
effects of actual immune activation
within that same tumor and and finally
it has as it is currently being
developed right now it is a centralized
model of performing the assay which
brings in logistical challenges to
deploying this essay and multi-site
clinical trials and finally since tumor
mutation burden is just measuring the
total mutational load it has no
abilities then to predict during
responses to immune check to combination
therapies where you might expect a more
complex signature like gene expression
profiling to give you additional
predictive power in that setting I
wanted to show one slide next that
you're seeing here that compares the
tumor inflammation signature to the PDL
one immunohistochemistry and so this is
an acid
sorry this is a test that was done in
head and neck cancers where patients
tumors were scored by the TI ASSA and
also by the PD on one si and those
results from each of those tests were
then compared to the clinical benefit
that was observed for those patients and
what you can see here is that the tumor
inflammation signature has better
predictive power than the PDL one assets
actually has higher sensitivity in this
test and the area under the curve is
greater suggesting that it has the
greater predictive power and better able
to identify patients that will respond
similarly when we compare the gif to to
tumor mutation burden again in the head
and neck cancer setting we see a very
interesting result and head and neck
cancer occurs from one of two causes if
there are either those patients who are
positive for the HPV virus and whose
tumors arise and tend to have very low
mutational burden and in these patients
as we're seeing on the left side of this
graph the tumor inflammation signature
has a very high predictive power because
it is measuring
the presence of the active immune system
within that tumor rather than the
potential immune activation as would be
indicated by looking just at mutational
burden alone similarly when you the
other cause of head and neck cancer is
is through exposure to carcinogenic
agents and in those patients then the
tumors that arise are negative for the
HPV virus these patients tend to have
higher mutation loads within their
tumors and in this case we see
predictive power from both the tumor
inflammation signature as well as the
mutational load profiling and so what
this tells us here is that in some cases
mutation load profiling can be can be
predictive in the clinical setting but
in all cases here we're seeing that
measuring the actual biology by looking
at the T is we're able to enrich for
those patients who are likely to then
respond to PD one checkpoint blockade so
I'd like to tell you then now about a
new panel that we are developing that
can be used to build upon the tumor
inflammation signature and more deeply
interrogate the biology of tumor immune
interactions and just to remind you that
this panel as as for all of our panels
is working on the nano strength platform
where we're using the targeted capture
and reporter probes that hybridize
specifically to the RNA from the sample
of interest and then reading those out
in a digital format so that we're
getting at the end of the day precise
quantitative counts that are reflective
of the presence of that particular
analyte within the within the sample
that is being interrogated and we build
these panels out to a enable
interrogation of up to 800 targets at
once and our goal with building
additional gene panels as always to
enable our customers to answer more
refined biological questions and that is
exactly what we wanted to do in this
such setting as well so we wanted to
leverage the power that we've been
developing around the tumor and
Meishan signature is a clinical assay
and build out a research use only
platform that could then be used to
further interrogate mechanisms of immune
evasion and the result of this effort
was a product that we call the
pan-cancer IO 360 gene expression panel
and the goal of this assay is really to
provide an actionable profile of tumour
immune interactions that can then help
guide research and development around
novel immunotherapies and so the way
that this assay works is that it
provides 800 gene expression profiles of
patient samples in these case
pretreatment tumor biopsies and it we
have incorporated on top of these a
series of signatures including our tumor
inflammation signature that can help
dissect the immune pathways that are
that are present within this particular
sample and then ultimately you know be
able to link those pathways back to
particular therapies which will induce
positive clinical outcomes for those
patients so the IO 360 panel has 770
genes built in and pre designed we also
have space open for 30 genes to be
included as a customized panel spikin
we've included 20 reference genes in
this panel and the panel itself has
tumor has content that that addresses
both the tumor specific signaling the
tumor microenvironment and the immune
response and within this panel we have
specifically developed individuals
signatures and pathways to characterize
the different biological activities that
will allow researchers to very quickly
understand and at a very deep level ask
questions about the the particular
interactions between the immune system
and and the tumor that that are being
interrogated in this research setting so
we've provided annotations about each of
the genes that are in these panels we've
also provided the signatures as
well as particular subsets of signatures
that are enable immune cell profiling
and I'm going to I give this
presentation over to my colleague dr.
Danaher in just a few minutes who will
tell you more about what each of those
signatures are and what they can do but
just to give you a very brief overview
of what these the kinds of biology that
these signatures are addressing you know
you can see here the gene content that
we have incorporated that interrogate in
a very holistic fashion signaling
patterns that can shape how tumors and
immune systems are interacting with each
other and this is just a list of those
particular signatures that have been
embedded into the panel and which are
available through our data analysis
services so when you leverage the i/o
360 panel in your research you get the
gene expression panel itself it's able
to be analyzed with the end silver
software as all of our other gene
expression panels are and then we've
built these signatures in as an added
level of functionality to really help
investigators ask the more detailed and
more refined questions about their
samples this is just very briefly one
paper which describes the cell type
profile profiling signatures that are
that are embedded in and just as an
example you know we can we can use this
panel we can use these signatures then
to understand how relative levels of
immune infiltrate vary from one sample
to enter to the next and I'm going to
very briefly mention the data analysis
service options so as I said all of the
annotations are available for this panel
to be used and and samples can be
analyzed through the end silver and the
advanced analyses software packages and
then we've also built additional data
analysis services where we can calculate
the precise signatures that are embedded
within these panels and provide back to
users a single sample and an multi
sample reports which allow you to
interact with the data in a very dynamic
and interactive way and very quickly
generate new
and I quickly advanced the research in
immuno on ecology and so as a result I
believe what we've built here is a
system which enables a very very easy
and very robust profiling of tumor
tissues to enable you know discovery of
new of new biology validation of new
hypotheses and creation of new biomarker
signatures that may be useful for
directing patients to the appropriate
immunotherapy the core of this IO 360
panel is called the tumor inflammation
signature it is measuring the the
existing adaptive immune response within
the tumors and it performs very well
when compared to immunohistochemistry
mutational load and then in addition to
the tumor inflammation signature we have
also built additional signatures around
the panel which can help you ask even
more detailed questions about the
biology of your sample and with that I'm
going to turn the presentation over to
dr. Danaher who's going to tell you more
about what these signatures are and what
they can do thank you thank you sir
so I'll describe briefly let's see both
the all the work that's gone is creating
this analysis service and then what the
analysis service can bring to any
particular data set you might have so I
guess the goal of the analysis service
is just to bring understanding to immune
oncology the expression data having a
data set with 800 genes and you know 10
or 100 samples is a it's a complex
matrix of a lot of numbers and it's hard
to extract a lot of meaning from that
especially if you're not a statistician
or if you're in Fermat Assist is a lot
of projects in this pipeline but it
seems to be the standard state of
affairs so yeah we just want to make it
easy to extract not only information but
understanding from your data so I guess
the first question is just given a
sample you give it a 2 or what do you
want to know about that sample you know
the first question of course is just is
it immune hot or cold so you know that
would be the simple test but then yeah
there's a lot of other things we'd want
to learn about the tumor I would want to
know what cell types are proud you know
what immune cell types are present in
the tumor and how abundant they are
really we want to know the whole every
detail of the cancer immunity cycle as
we currently understand it how foreign
does the tumor appear is it accessible
to the immune system or are there
structural barriers the immune system
that is in the tumor uh what are those
cells doing are they exhausted or are
they actively cytotoxic and then how was
the tumor responding to the immune
system is it expressing a lot of
checkpoint and other inhibitory
molecules or you know as a growing as a
dying is it you know responding
interferon signalling all questions you
know that we understand the biology and
it would be really nice if we could
measure them in some way so a big part
of this the analysis services creating
tools to measure the variables we care
about everything I just talked about so
the first thing to begin with Sara Sara
mentioned all these signatures we've
generated and I think it's worth
describing a little bit how we actually
derive these signatures there are
probably more genes signatures that have
been published in actual genes in the
genome so it's a deserves a bit of
explanation why these signatures are
actually useful and that deserve deserve
attention let's say so we've got a
pretty rigorous process and a pretty
selective process you know we attempt
signatures for great many biological
variables and we actually fail our
signatures
good percentage of the time just for not
having strong enough evidence so the
basic outline of our process is as
follows we begin with known biology we
want to measure say cytotoxic activity
we use biological dollars but searches
to derive to come up with a gene list
that is likely to be mechanistically
involved in cytotoxic activity so you
know just from the get-go it's very
plausible that expression of any of
these genes ought to measure cytotoxic
activity but you know of course we're
not going to be right all the time yet
many genes are regulated after as a
regulated at the protein level or are
influenced by a number of factors not
just the activity we want to measure and
so many of our candidate genes just
aren't going to measure you know
whatever biological process we care
about or you know many of our
cytotoxicity genes for example might
actually just be expressed at constant
levels and all cd8 cells
you know just ready to be activated at
the protein level and so you know we
think we're measuring cytotoxicity with
these genes but actually we're just
looking at cd8 T cells so there's a lot
of ways we can go wrong if we just stick
to biologically derived gene lists so we
take a second step after using the
literature to come up with a candidate
gene list we use Co expression analysis
in TCGA to winnow down our gene list to
test the the genes are performing as
they ought to if they are indeed
measuring what we think they are I'll go
more into that but the basic idea is we
define ahead of time okay if these genes
are actually measuring in cytotoxicity
what Co expression patterns should they
display and then we can just look at
their Co expression patterns in TCGA see
how well they adhere to the pattern we
expect we can remove genes or entire
gene lists as needed based on how well
the data agrees with with our predefined
model mm-hmm so to make this a little
more concrete let me start with a failed
example of a signature we wanted to
create a signature of t-cell Co
inhibitory signaling you might expect
there could be some variable of how
receptive t-cells are to Co inhibitory
signaling and how much Co inhibitory
signaling is actively affecting those
t-cells so we chose using literature a
good number of cone inventory genes
just showing four of them here and yeah
you'd expect that if these four canada
jeans all measured co inhibitory
signaling they would be pretty close
with each other is that biological
process went up or down it would drive
all those genes to go up or down and you
know that would induce correlation
amongst them and if we look at the
normalized data this is a TCGA melanoma
plot on the left here you can see that
just normalized gene expression data
these genes do correlate quite well with
each other
yeah they appear to be measuring the
same thing but we're not satisfied with
that we apply a few more conditions we
want to make sure these genes are
measuring what we think they're
measuring and not just some other
variable that happens to drive their Co
expression so we take the normalized
data and we regress each of these genes
on a number of other factors that we are
worried might infer might influence
their expression so here are the obvious
and obvious factors t-cell abundance we
have a signature for that so address
these genes on that as well have a
number as well as a number of other
variables were concerned about and then
we look at the residuals of the scenes
from the regressions and if we look at
the plot on the right now we can see
that once we regress out all these other
signatures we were worried about no Co
expression amongst these genes remains
so while these four genes might be
measuring the same thing that thing is
not some independent variable of t-cell
Co inhibitory signaling the thing
they're measuring is probably just T
cell abundance so in this is the case of
a failed gene signature for a successful
case we wanted to look at a antigen
presentation by the MHC class 2 so here
again are just four of the genes we
looked at and the normalized data we see
they're highly correlated so they're
definitely measuring the same thing it's
an encouraging start but we're not
satisfied with that so we regress on ten
other variables we regress on signatures
the abundance of a number of antigen
present state present presenting cell
populations as well as other variables
that we know broadly influence gene
expression the amount of proliferation
and a tumor general signatures of
lymphoid and maia light abundance stroma
signature and then just good measure the
first three principal components of the
data and what we see is after
conditioning on these 10 pretty powerful
variables you know they explain quite a
lot of the transcriptome on the right we
see that the correlation most of the
correlation amongst these four genes
remains
so at this point I think it's fair to
say that these four genes are measuring
the same thing and that thing is
probably antigen presentation by the MHC
class 2 and not some other factor like
b-cell abundance urge and dread Excel
abundance so this is the kind of
lovingness we evidence we demand of our
genus before we can combine them and do
a signature all right so with the
background out of the way I'll proceed
to show with an example of how these
signatures can help understand it hope
you understand the data set and get a
little more statistical power to booth
so this data set is tumors treated with
a checkpoint inhibitor we've got 34 it's
a small data set just 34 were
non-responders and just 8 responders so
we're not spectacularly powered here in
this data set we're actually looking at
almost 2,000 genes instead of just the
800 in our panel the panel unfortunately
wasn't available at the time let's see
yeah so the first thing to point out is
just that when you look at signatures
instead of single genes just by the
simple fact of cutting you're cutting
the number of variables you're looking
at you gain a lot of statistical power
now I'm assuming that this proposition
only works if the signatures are
actually relevant to the biology in
question which they are in this case so
if we look at the the top two plots here
I'm just doing differential expression
of genes and signatures the volcano plot
from genes is on the top right four
signatures is on the top left so
different familiar with these plots
horizontal axis shows differential
expression between responders and
non-responders
vertical axis shows statistical
significance with everything above the
dotted line being a 0.05 p-value or
better so if we look at the signatures
we see that many are significant you
know good number falls off 0.05 and if
we look at the genes you know old hunter
really significant you know some pretty
tiny p-value is there some below 0.001
so there's a lot of information in both
cases here but of course we can't just
test 2009 policies and be satisfied with
the p-value cutoff of 0.05 we need to do
some sort of adjustments for
multiplicity and to make sure we're not
getting excited about genes just because
they were lucky instead of actually
useful
so we perform a false discovery rate
correction and obtain the volcano plots
on the bottom if you look at the
signatures now plotting FDR on the
vertical axis false discovery ratings at
the p-value we find that many of the
signatures end up with a false discovery
rate just around point O 5 you know it
happened to be a little bit below but
that's not really the point here you
know the point is about half our
signatures we've got a pretty strong
conclusion to be made you know we're not
100% confident but we expect that less
than 5% of these discoveries will go on
to be false if we look at the bottom
right volcano plot false discovery rate
of our single genes we find that even
our strongest p-values is below point
zero zero one
they only amount to a false discovery
rate of about 70 percent so we're really
left with no high confidence conclusions
here and this is just the basic fact of
working with high dimensional data in a
small study you know unless you have a
truly spectacular effect size you're
never going to see anything with high
confidence but in this study if we if we
stuck with genes we would have been
unable to make high confidence
conclusions that have just been able to
say there's some interesting genes but
we'll just need to collect more data to
see if they validate if we begin our
analysis by focusing on signatures on
the smaller dimension but still highly
useful instead of variables we actually
end up with some confidence another use
of the signatures is not statistical
power is just simple understanding your
data you know there's a lot of genes and
many of us know what many of them do but
it's still pretty confusing looking at
differential expression results for
hundreds of genes you know maybe half of
what you've heard of if you've been
working in the field a while so on the
right now I'm just showing how all of
our signatures differ between responders
and non-responders and a florist's plot
so the box is the estimate and the line
is a confidence interval for the effect
size so ever thing to the right is
upregulated responders person on
responders if you can see a pretty quick
glance that there are quite a few
signatures that are upregulated
responders and looking at them they're
generally the signatures involved in
adaptive immunity so largely members of
the lymphoid compartment and their
associated activities so cd8 cells or
cytotoxic activity
or interferon-gamma signaling that sort
of variable variables signatures
associated with the myeloid compartment
like dendritic cells macrophages
neutrophils those are generally not
different or on average they're not
different between responders and
non-responders so they don't appear to
be informative for that distinction here
and then incidentally Arjun ace is that
one point out on the left it's the
single variable were looking at that's
upregulated non-responders so it's Bratz
it's an important inhibitory factor here
so the signatures are interesting
individually but they're also in
combination with each other so looking
here I'm just plotting three interesting
signatures against the tumor information
signature I think an important point is
that many immune variables are pretty
correlated with each other as the immune
system goes into a tumor it all goes in
both the cd8 cells and you have many
many other cell populations as well so
it can often be hard to pull out
information from this tight correlation
so we find that just plotting variables
or regression variables against the
tests allows us to see in a little more
detail what they're actually doing so
this plot on the top left looking at
macrophages versus I thought was pretty
interesting here the responders are in
red non-responders are in blue you can
see that to be a responder you have to
have a high test and all the red points
are on the right side of the graph but
if you have a high test it looks like
it's helpful to actually have lower
macrophages rather than higher
macrophages it's you know on the border
of statistical significance not quite
there but it's a end result that
deserves more follow-up you might expect
that these macrophages are performing as
a Mallee dressed repressor cells in
these samples and so highly immune
active sample you know I mean hot sample
with a high test that also had a lot of
macrophages that immunosuppressive
access of MDS CS might not be adequately
dealt with but as checkpoint drug and so
that sample would remain a non responder
if we looked at macrophages alone you
know just that one variable one we
wouldn't see this you know the average
macrophage score is the same between
responders and non-responders
but asking after conditioning on the
test it actually becomes interesting
and finally I want to show how these
signatures can be used to understand
even a single sample so of this data set
I've picked out what I think is the most
interesting sample it's a very high
tumor information signatures scores a
very immune hot tumor but nonetheless
didn't respond so Barry's asking this
tumor is immune hot what kept it from
being pushed and successful in
anti-tumor immunity by this checkpoint
in inhibitor yeah so we can look at
these signatures and try to see how this
timber looks in them so it'll start at
the top right with antigen availability
I look at signatures for antigen
presentation machinery for the immuno
proteasome for destruction of the
antigen presentation machinery or for a
mismatch repair deficiency and looking
at these top four signatures I see very
high levels of antigen presentation no
degradation of the presentation
machinery and possibly some evidence for
some mismatched repair deregulation so
if anything this tumor is highly visible
to the immune system its presenting yeah
it's very actively presenting the
antigen so nothing here to hold back in
the munis panse
looking on the next row at variables
involved in anti-tumor immunity again
you know we see very high really
encouraging values of you know highly
abundant cd8 cells a lot of cytotoxic
activity and a lot of interfering GABA
signaling now this is a fully
functioning highly active immune
response and everything's here suggest
since patients who should have responded
as well and then on the bottom right we
can look at inhibitory factors and all
these various checkpoint or other
inhibitory molecules they're high but
they're actually not high conditional on
the patient's tumor information score
you know just looking at PDL 1 versus
test for example PDL 1 is quite high but
all samples with high tests have high
PDL one so we shouldn't be particularly
concerned about this patients response
based on the the high PDL one so we
don't find an explanation here now where
we do get an answer I think is in
looking at the Arjun ace expression of
this patient looking at Arjun is in
general I see two clusters there's a
cluster which has basically no
expression on the bottom there
and then this more diffuse cluster which
has moderate very high expression and
this sample had particularly high
expression of RJ's and of course we saw
earlier that our geneious was quite
predictive of response versus
non-response so if I was to explain this
patient I would say that metabolic
factors that our generation is involved
in are probably what's holding back the
response here so a major goal of a lot
of studies within the translational
setting is to actually not just
understand the biology behind response
to not response abut to create a
particular response to have a diagnostic
that could exclude non responders from a
clinical trial for example or identify
the patients for your drug is going to
benefit so benefit patients more than
the standard of care so in this case we
also find that our signatures end up
contributing statistical power and yet
enable win success so this is a simple
not-quite simulation study I took the
same data set and I split it into a
hundred train and training and test sets
it needs two training set I tried to
signature either so I turned to
predictor of response either using only
genes or only signature scores or both
and then I tested that signatures
predictiveness and the in the data I
have left out so we've got a hundred
different attempts to train a signature
and then independently validate it now
what I'm plotting here is the test set
area under the ROC curve of each of
those 100 or 300 train signatures so you
know remember when we looked in our OC
curve area under the curve point 5 means
you have a random predictor an area
under the curve of 1 means you have a
perfect predictor so we see here if we
train using only genes or test fit area
under the curve is pretty weak and
pretty variable sometimes it's even
worse than random if you turn using
signatures the average performance goes
up substantially from around 0.5 5 to
about 0.75 so a pretty huge jump in
performance and the key here is just we
don't have a very big data set so
machine learning using 2,000 features
for
only 40 or so samples is just it's hard
battle yeah no matter how sophisticated
and machine learning method that to
mention to sample size ratio is just
going to create a lot of problems for
whereas if we can excuse me if we can
focus on the variables that matter yeah
the variable so we already expect are
going to be relevant to the problem that
we've tried to capture with these
signatures and so if we can look at
fewer variables we can give ourselves a
lot of statistical power so the our data
analysis service has a has unique method
for trying to optimally combine genes
and signatures to create predictors of
response we don't want to wholly lean on
our signatures but we think we can add a
lot of value by heavily weighting them
over the genes another thing we do this
analysis service to try for each sample
to identify for each given sample what
are the factors holding back the immune
response why is it why does the immune
system not already killed this this
chamber and the hope is you know one day
that will have a will have an
amelioration for each of these factors
that you can imagine some future future
timber being assayed and we'll see that
okay it's got these two high inhibitory
factors and it's lagging in this and you
know activating factors so let's address
each of those three each of those three
factors it is an example of how this
works the plot on the top right we see
this this tumor had very high
interleukin 10 and so you know
inhibitory factors so that might be you
know that I'm usually high expression
might be a problem for this patient
might might be holding back their immune
response the middle plot we see very
high ctla4 actually this is kind of
interesting that normally ctla4 tracks
hiss but in melanomas it seems that
ctla4 has this other cluster very high
ctla4 despite being otherwise Indian
cold and this is one of those patients
and I think tto a for-expression is a
pretty good explanation for why this
particular tumor has been able to evade
the immune system the fun we also four
signatures that are immune activating
the signatures that are lagging behind
the rest of the
in response so this sample on the bottom
right is very low in it I guess it is
kind of middle-of-the-road and it's in
presentation machinery signature but
conditional on the rest of its immune
activity it's really low
you know conditional on work on it's
very high test that is it's very low so
what seems to be happening in this
sample there's high immune activity lots
of t-cells and cd8 t-cells that of
toxicity interfering gamma signaling but
for some reason it ended in presentation
machinery it's just not keeping up with
that so it might be that the tumor is
somehow down regulated that you know
down regulated b2m for example to try to
evade immune detection and this is the
kind of barrier that is probably pretty
hard to treat and you might make this
I'm promising a tumor to treat with
immunotherapy
despite its immune hot status finally
independent of all the signatures
there's more of the gene expression can
say about the tumors immune state there
was a fascinating paper recently by
Apatow and Recife which uses CRISPR
screens to identify genes that are
essential for response to immunotherapy
they found 30 or so genes that if
disabled rendered a tumor resistant to
immunotherapy and it turns out that a
lot of these genes you can identify many
outliers low levels of them many loss of
expression events just looking at
primary tumors in TCGA so in these top
two examples sox10 and mln a you can see
in one case infrequent and another case
fairly abundant instances of loss of
expression and I think it would be a
reasonable hypothesis that these loss of
expression tumors are less promising and
responders to immune immunotherapy so of
course that has to be tested but it's
always good to be able to identify these
events when they happen other variables
are a little more a little harder to
pick out that we can do so v2 n is
probably the most famous gene that's
required for response to checkpoint
inhibition and basically b2m is a really
wide expression range so it's hard to
say if a particular sample is unusually
low b2m expression but if we plot B to
them against other antigen presenting
we can actually resolve some of that or
we can condense some of that variability
so from the bottom right plot there are
many samples that have
middle-of-the-road b2m you know take
this sample for example it's got pretty
average levels of B to M but conditional
on the rest of the it's antigen
presentation machinery that's really low
it seems like b2 this is all in the log
to a log to scale so that's about 8 fold
down regulated from where we would
expect it to be as this sample so in
these cases it seems like b2 m has been
drastically down regulated possibly in a
adapt a adaptation to help the tumor
avoid the immune system so just another
variable that we can use to describe
what's happening in the tumor immune
interface using gene expression all
right well that's all I have to share
there where nasarah said we're actively
developing this analysis service we're
constantly adding variables to it new
signatures new analyses as we discover
them and yeah our goal is just to take a
complex data set and make it
understandable you render it into the
variables that we understand as
biologists rather than is computational
experts thank you very much and I think
we're happy to take questions I thank
you dr. Warren dr. Danaher for that
informative presentation and for your
important research we now will start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button in the lower left of
the presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's take a look at
our audience questions already coming in
and thank you audience for your live
participation our first question is is
the T is likely to predict response to
other immune checkpoint therapies and
either one of you can go ahead and
answer that yeah I can take that answer
thank you very much that's a really good
question right the T is was the
to measure the inflamed tumor State and
as such we we are very hopeful that it
will be able to predict other immune
therapies we are currently endure under
investigations that will allow us to
answer this question with greater detail
and we look forward to sharing these
data with you as they become available
we will have some of this data available
at 50 and we are continuing to develop
and publish other other datasets that
will help us answer this question thank
you doctor 1 and here's our next
question are there any advantages to
using gene expression based assays as
biomarkers versus other conventional
technologies sure I can take that one as
well so gene expression assays are a
very powerful tool for understanding the
fundamental biology of what of the
system that you're studying because we
can leverage the highly quantitative
nature of the nanna string platform to
create these gene expression profiles
and because we can look in multiplexed
gene expression space it allows us to
create more complex and more nuanced
predictive signatures that can help
identify patients who may be more likely
to respond to one therapy versus another
and so that can help us to avoid some of
the heterogeneity that has been
introduced into other samples based upon
variable expression of a single
biomarker readout and it can also allow
us to begin to for instance segregate
out patients who would respond better to
a combination therapy from a mono
therapy and those are two aspects of
signature development that other assets
currently in development are not able to
address today
thank you we have time for one more
question and again I want to thank our
audience and let them know that our
speakers today are willing to take
further emailed questions or questions
and they will email their responses
our last question that we have time for
is is it tea is relevant for indicating
patients to novel immuno therapies
versus single agent anti pd-1 or PDL one
I can take this one thanks yes that's a
really good question so when I see that
when I look at data from a small
clinical trial and I see that response
to a therapy is correlated with the
children formation signature I say great
maybe your your risk for responses and
hot tumors you know we can improve the
power of your trial because we can
exclude the Indian coal tumors and get
rid of a bunch of non-responder as well
holding on to the responders the other
situation of course that we see
immunotherapy that who's in which
response is not correlated with the test
in which case I say this is really great
we can it looks like your drug works
just the wall in the munich old patients
as an immune ha patients in the munich
old patients you've got a really strong
argument for using this drug or this
combination a versus single agent
checkpoint inhibition we're asking the
in hot patients you know maybe this
extra combination and this newer drug
isn't going to have much of a
performance benefit against say pimple
isn't a verbal lab so i i guess whatever
the case is you can either you you want
to know both where where's my would
patience my drug going to help and
secondly with patients on my drug health
versus the single agent standard of care
and however you perform across the
immunity cold spectrum there's
information to be gained from the timber
information signature and then I would
hope lots of information to be gained
from these other signatures you know
they're diverse mechanisms of a
resistance immunotherapy and you know we
think we can capture a great many of
them with the expression wonderful
thank you both did you either one of you
or both of you would like to make a
closing remark before we end our webinar
today sure no I just wanted to say thank
you very much to the audience for
joining us for the last hour we hope
that you found the information that we
presented informative and and intriguing
for your research if it's something you
would like to explore more I would
encourage you to go to our website nana
string comm where you can find more
information about the io 360 panel the
tumor inflammation signature and some of
the data analysis services that we have
available and there are contact pages
throughout the website that can put you
in touch with our our scientists and our
representatives at the companies who can
help you learn how to bring naina string
profiling into your research thank you
and I want to thank you both again for
your important research and your
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor nano string for
making today's educational webcast
possible audience members before we go I
want to remind everyone that today the
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when the webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye